SPEAKER: Friction, it's good for
rock climbing and opening jars,
but in the world
of app development,
it's a force that
we seek to minimize.
App installation is a
major source of friction.
Even for small apps,
the installation screen
can lose you 5% to
10% of your users.
And the numbers just get worse
as the app size gets larger.
For example, 20% of app
installs over 100 megabytes
are canceled by the user.
This is where Android
Instant Apps really shines.
Instant apps are
native Android apps
that require no installation.
But what the heck does
that actually mean?
Let's go ahead and take a look.
Here, I've got a link from a
friend about the Google Trips
app.
I press it, and I'm immediately
taken into an instant app
experience.
It feels like a native
app because it is one.
Instant apps can be associated
with any URL that you own.
So you can associate
an instant app
with a search result, a tweet,
a text message, or a "Try Now"
button on your
Play Store listing.
Let's go ahead and
take a look at how
you'd actually go about
structuring your app
to be instant.
You're most likely used
to having a single app
module like this.
When you compile your
app, it becomes an APK
that you then upload
to Google Play.
As you add different features
and assets to your app,
that APK size is going to grow.
Eventually, your
single app module
is going to take
minutes to download.
Now, you haven't really taken
the friction out of the app
experience if your users will
spend the same amount of time
staring at that instant
app's splash screen
that they would
have spent looking
at the installing screen.
So instant apps enable you
to keep all of the features
that your users love, but
download them one at a time.
To do this, you need to
take that one big app module
and split it into smaller
modules called feature modules.
Each feature module contains
the code and resources
for a different, distinct
thing that your users
could do with your app.
So for example, let's say
that I have a travel app.
I might have a
different feature module
for the code for
renting hotel rooms,
booking flights, and
rating those hotel rooms.
Now usually, these
feature modules
won't have completely
independent code or resources.
You probably use the same
themes and utility code in each.
You also probably use
the support library
in all of the feature modules.
All of this shared
code and resources
is therefore extracted out
into another module, which is
called the base feature module.
When your user
opens your app, they
don't download the whole app.
They only download the code
for the base feature module
and the feature module that
they're currently using.
This means that if your user
is booking a hotel room,
they're not necessarily
going to download
the code for flights or rating.
If your user then navigates
to another feature of yours,
the base feature
isn't redownloaded.
And because you've
modularized your code,
you can use the same code
base for your installable app
as your instant app.
Now, behind the scenes, when you
compile as an installable app,
these different
feature modules will
act like a collection
of Android libraries.
But when they're compiled
as an instant app,
you're going to get a
ZIP file, which you then
upload to Google Play.
This ZIP file contains separate
APKs for each feature module.
At runtime, these APKs are
loaded and composited together
to provide the instant
apps experience.
Android Studio 3.0 has
been designed with tools
to help you modularize
and create instant apps.
It includes a refactoring
tool for splitting code
into modules.
The App Links assistant
makes it easy to generate
the code needed to
associate the URLs that you
own with your instant
app feature modules.
There's also an Instant Apps
SDK with NDK support and APIs
for showing install prompts.
The cookie API makes it
easy to transfer data
from the instant app
to the installable app.
And configuration APK support
helps you reduce module size.
More details on all of this
are in the Docs link below.
The 3.0 Android Gradle
plugin was built
with multi-module apps in mind.
And it compiles
multi-module projects fast.
This table shows speeds for
a project with 130 modules.
Finally, there are two new
plugin types specifically
for building instant apps--
the feature plugin for your
feature modules and the Instant
App plugin.
OK, so as we saw
before, you have
modules for all of your features
and the base feature module.
You're also going to include
two additional modules
just for building the app--
the Installable app module which
builds your installable app,
and the Instant App module
which builds your instant app.
The Installable App module uses
the Gradle application plugin.
But the Instant App module
uses the new Gradle instant app
plugin.
Your feature modules then
use the new Feature plugin.
The Feature plugin
is kind of cool
because it will make either
an APK versus a library,
depending on whether
it's being built
by the Instant App or the
Installable App module.
Now, after using the correct
Gradle plugins for each of your
build files, you just have
to set up the dependencies
between the modules.
Then you're ready to build both
instant and installable apps.
For some hands-on experience
converting a regular app
to an instant app, check out the
Android Instant Apps Codelab.
Now, if you are itching
to convert your own app,
we also have tons of
documentation and resources
about the requirements and
processes for getting started.
And if you ever
find yourself stuck,
you can reach out
on Stack Overflow
with the
android-instant-apps tag.
That's it for today.
Happy building.
[MUSIC PLAYING]